[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
if you've been around this channel for a
while you'll know that i love looking
out for free to play games and the new
experiences
they offer vigor is a game i've been
monitoring
for a long time and it's now available
on playstation alongside xbox and twitch
to celebrate vigor on ps4 and ps5 i've
teamed up with bohemia interactive to
show you why you should download it
and play it for yourself there's a link
in the description should you need it
and because this is a sponsored post we
have battle passes for vigor
on playstation to give away i'll put
them in the comments below
let's set the scene vigor takes place in
norway
yes way we're going to scandinavia set
back in 1991 after a war has ripped
europe apart
and humanity is breathing its last gasps
of survival
but this apocalypse isn't the cliched
zombie hordes
it's filled with real life players with
the same core goal
survive at all costs
vigor is a looter shooter in mechanics
but it's nothing like borderlands vigor
plays more like dayz
or escape from tarkov and if you're
getting daisy vibes right away then it
won't surprise you that the developers
bohemia interactive created that
franchise too
we are sent into moderate-sized maps and
face off directly with other players
it's actually possible to check their
loadouts before the game even begins
to change your tactics on the fly and
from there the objective
is simple grab as much loot and upgrade
items as possible
then leave the map through the multiple
exit points shown in orange
simple right it's possible to get in and
get out unseen
as survival is the main ingredient here
although gunplay
is a very close second well let's spice
things up vigor is ready to punish us
all because get this when we die in game
we lose all the items we are currently
holding
it's all gone if we crafted a p90 and
lose it in the field
it won't be available in your next
encounter this single call mechanic
changes everything in a way which is
really hard to explain
it's a feeling you may not have felt
before the risk reward vigor offers is
something we don't regularly see in
gaming
but as the term risk reward tells us the
possibility of losing things
is counteracted by the possibility of
gaining so much
i personally took every encounter as an
opportunity
if someone had a weapon i'd never seen
before in the pre-lobby
i'd be sure to hunt them down and try
and loot that weapon
before leaving and taking everything
home there are other things at work as
you do this but the core loop is
prepare for a mission by choosing your
loadout looting and shooting through
that mission
finding extraction and bringing home all
your plundered treasure
to add to this are a bunch of elements
to keep gameplay fresh and tactical
there are safe locations which require
two buttons to be pressed at unknown
places to access the loot
there's a huge container full of high
level loot which requires combination
locks to decipher before opening
and fyi your controller rumbles to
signal the correct number in each column
the higher the loot rarity the more
likely other players will be nearby so
be ready to fight if you go for these
things
the final crescendo of each encounter is
a supply drop
and because it's christmas right now
vigor has called in
a pro to drop off the final crate
santa is just one of the regular updates
you can expect to find playing vigor but
i don't think he'll be here all year
round
anyway back to the final crate this
airdrop is where the potential for the
best loot lies
the entire encounter lasts about 15
minutes unless you extract early
but those who stay to the end have one
thing in common they all want that final
drop
some players use the cash as bait others
get in and get out and escape as quickly
as possible
the kicker is everyone knows where the
final drop is
and once it's picked up the entire lobby
know your location constantly
making for extremely tense final moments
risk reward is everything in this game
and it's brilliant
oh and one more thing stay too long and
toxic radiation will engulf the map
keep an eye out for these markers which
represent the flow of radiation
if you're successful and escape with the
supply drop it's now waiting for you
back at base and looks like this
and it's all linked to rarity and tears
so you may be wondering why are we
collecting glass
and nails and grow bags that is for our
home
the shelter everyone has their own
version of this place
and in between missions we return here
to plan the next encounter
and upgrade our utilities this aspect of
vigor
most surprised me and became the reason
i wanted to play more
this hub shelter is the entire reason we
loot
every single resource we bring back
helps build this home
this is both visually the shelter gets
overhauled and becomes your dream house
and of course every dream house needs a
bunker full of weapons that you can
craft
and your favorite music can be played on
guitar
[Music]
but this goes far beyond looking nice
each upgrade
impacts your gameplay or future choices
the key upgrade
is your crafting table get this upgraded
as soon as you can
this will be the spot we construct all
our weapons using the materials we find
in the field
and that's the same for ammo and meds as
we unlock blueprints more weapons are
craftable and
our arsenal grows other areas shouldn't
be neglected either
upgrading the wood log will actually
generate materials every hour
the utility room upgrade reduces the
cost of consumables
and check this one out the antenna at
the shelter can be upgraded
and allows you to earn 3.39 crowns a day
at a base rate that's the in-game
currency
constantly being earned when you're not
playing sheer madness
literally giving us free money to spend
in-game
one of the key uses for crowns are
cosmetic items and the battle pass
and this season is the season of the
junkers a new set of weapons and
cosmetic items which link into the
post-apocalyptic junk
vibe like you see in mad max or fallout
3.
we've all become accustomed to a battle
pass and like usual there's a free
version and there's a version which is
premium you'll need crowns to buy it
unlike many other games every single
tier has a reward
from crowned to crates to military-grade
weapons
the premium tier offers the most
customization options and links back to
the junker theme
hockey masks air force attire everything
is themed to the season
and once that season's gone you can't
get this stuff anymore and i've noticed
as this is a new game on playstation
it's extra nice
to stand out and look intimidating in
the pre-game lobby
crowns do a few more things in vigor at
the start of each game we can use these
credits to ensure our loadout
thus removing the risk we were talking
about earlier with insurance purchased
your weapons and loot
are safe even if you die in game and
that includes anything you pick up
whilst you're in game we can also use
crowns to boost the drop rate and
quality of loot in each encounter
including the final crate drop upping
the ante for everyone in game
hey i don't want to throw too much your
way just know there's more to vigor than
meets the eye
initially the most recent update also
includes nighttime variants of maps and
a whole brand new map to celebrate
season six
anakin anakin and nikon anakin
i am terrible at speaking norwegian i'm
sorry for butchering that word
we now have armor plates to take more
damage in a gunfight and new weapons
drop every season too
like the rpk 74 which i'm still learning
to control
vigor keeps evolving and i'm excited to
see how things keep moving forward
if you want to play with friends that is
totally possible and changes the entire
dynamic of a battle
i've noticed that in duos losing your
partner
makes survival so much harder and in
trios
you'll likely have a friend who runs off
alone and gets filled full of lead
if they go down be sure to take their
loot for yourself
some encounters can go by without
fighting which can make you rusty over
time
i recommend trying another game mode
shootout this supports teams of up to
five
or standalone queuing if you prefer and
lets you practice your aim
and typical fights you'll encounter in
survival mode the weapons are randomized
too letting you get a feel for things
before crafting them in your home base
in just a single 10 minute game you'll
see more fighting than you would in 10
survival games so this is a really good
method to keep your battle hardened
overall i think vigor offers something
that we can't currently find on the
free-to-play market
something which doesn't lean into battle
royale and instead makes survival the
core mechanic
at present the playstation version of
vigor only allows playstation players to
play against each other
cross platform isn't here just yet i
don't know about you but that makes me
happy that we're all equal and we know
everyone is either on ps4 or ps5
when we load into an encounter i'll keep
you updated on if and when this changes
as i hear the switch community around
this game is pretty sizable
one day we shall play together i'm adam
from playstation grenade
thank you to bohemia once again for
sponsoring this video and allowing me to
cover it in more depth
much appreciated hopefully you enjoyed
this i'll see you next time
[Music]